-Looking sharp, buddy. -Thank you.
-Thank you for coming onto the show.
I want to say, you know, I'm a big fan of Weird Al Yankovic.
I watched "Weird."
If you haven't seen that documentary,
mockumentary type of --
If you haven't seen it, it's super funny.
And you pop up as one of my all-time favorites,
Pee Wee Herman. -There I am.
There I am. It was a little --
It was a little shocking to see
how much I actually look like him in real life.
The minute the beard was gone, I was like,
"Oh, yeah, yeah, I can see it."
-You were fantastic. -Thank you.
-How did you get into that?
-I begged my way in, was how I -- how I did it.
We were supposed to do a cameo,
the three of us, like, as The Lonely Island.
Like, me, Andy, and Akiva. -Yeah.
-And it coincided with Andy having his second child.
Congratulations. -Wow. Yeah...
[ Cheers and applause ] -Yeah Children!
And so, unfortunately, like,
it wasn't going to work on the shoot date.
So I called -- I called Weird Al,
and I was like, "Hey, I will do anything to be in this movie.
Like, I'll fly myself out. Whatever."
-"I'll be anything."
-And he called me 20 minutes later
and he was like, "I talked to Eric.
Would you want to be Pee Wee Herman?"
And I was like, "Yeah, yeah. Like, absolutely."
-Even better. -Yeah.
-So, did you talk to -- Do you know Paul Reubens?
-Yes. I do know Paul.
And I was terrified that he was going to hate every --
everything that I was doing.
-Did you call him before you did it?
-I didn't call him because I was told that I shouldn't.
Like, 'cause, they were -- they were trying to have
everything be a surprise.
So, like, I did my thing. It's a short little bit.
-I know, but it works. -But I got to --
I got to do, you know, the --
[ Pee Wee Herman laugh ]
-Yeah! That's so good!
-"Hi!" -It was fantastic.
So, let's talk about this. This is a big deal.
I'm so excited to have you on to talk about this.
You get to direct not one, but two
giant Super Bowl commercials.
This is massive. For Pepsi. -Yeah.
-You have -- Dude, you're directing --
Millions of people are going to see what you directed.
-Yeah. -This is cool.
-This is the first time. Because I've made a bunch of movies.
-Oh, yeah.
-And people are actually gonna see this one.
-[ Laughs ] -So that's very exciting.
-There's two up-and-coming stars
in different -- They're different ads.
One is Ben Stiller. The other one is Steve Martin.
-Yes.
-Did you know Steve from "Saturday Night Live"?
-I -- I -- There was --
Maybe our worst failure that we've ever had on "SNL"
was a sketch called "Surf Meeting" that we wrote.
And there was a thing that would happen, like,
when we were at "SNL," where if it would get to a certain point
at night and I'd be laughing a certain way,
Andy would always be like, "It's not gonna work.
Jorm's laughing in that Jorm way. It's not gonna work."
But we wrote this sketch called "Surf Meeting,"
which was a guy -- And it's a group of surfers.
And it's just -- And Andy's running the surf meeting.
And he's like, "There's somebody in our crew
that doesn't fit in, you guys.
Like, we don't like him."
And then it just cuts to Steve.
And he's like, "Who is this un-gnarly dude?"
And the thing about "SNL" is that it's moving at such a --
You know how it is. Like, if you block something
and it's not working, like, that's it.
You're just like, "Well, that's gonna go to air like that."
And, like, we were like, "Your time is done."
And we were like, "This isn't going to work."
-I have a picture of the sketch.
-He -- I've got to say. He sold it super hard.
He sold it super hard.
But between dress and air, I went in to give him, like,
last-minute notes, and he was like,
"It doesn't work, does it?"
And I was like, "No, it doesn't."
I was like, "Good luck, man." And he was like, "Yeah, sorry."
-At least you were honest with him.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah. -I want to show a teaser clip.
Here's a teaser for Jorma's Pepsi Super Bowl commercials.
Take a look at this.
-Hi. I'm Ben Stiller. -And I'm Steve Martin.
-As actors, in a way, we never really stop acting.
-For example, Ben is acting right now
like he's not intimidated standing next to me.
-And Steve's acting like he's not lucky to be here.
-Oh, and Ben's acting like that whole awkward thing he does
is a character and not his actual personality.
-And Steve's acting like, "Oh, I'm Steve Martin,"
when really, he's not so -- It's like, okay, we get it.
You're like -- I mean, whatever. You know --
-See what I mean? -Okay. Banjo player.
-Nepo baby.
[ Laughter ]
-That's good.
Jorma Taccone, everybody.
-And how about that directing?!
-No, that directing is what I'm talking about.
Jorma's Pepsi commercials
air during the Super Bowl this Sunday on Fox.
We'll be right back with a performance from Lang Lang.
Stick around, everybody.